This video is brought to you by keeps
What's up. Guys, Jared,
here to talk to you about something that's as American as canceling your Amazon
prime trial immediately. After getting two day shipping on a Nintendo switch,
I'm talking about the art of convincing you to buy stuff.
Advertising occupies a strange place in our collective imagination.
We revile it when it interrupts our beloved YouTube videos.
We talk about it way too much when it's super bowl season and frequently ignore
it unless it features Kendall Jenner, single-handedly ending racism.
But what if we told you that advertising aside from being an annoying
interrupter of content shaped America in ways you never imagined possible,
want to know how stick around for this wisecrack edition on how advertising
changed America and appropriately enough for a video about ads.
We want to thank keeps for sponsoring this video,
spending all this time at home. I've had a chance to reflect on myself.
There are some things I want to work on and some things that I don't want to
change. For example,
I never want to lose my hair and would do anything to prevent it.
After all the key to combating hair loss is prevention keeps makes it easy
because they offer FDA approved over the counter and prescription medication and
deliver it right to your front door. The process is so easy.
You simply meet with an online doctor and get the medication shipped to your
home. Keeps works to save the hair that you have.
And some men even experienced hair regrowth,
find out why keeps has more five-star reviews than any of its competitors.
And why nearly 100,000 men trust keeps for their hair loss prevention medication
by clicking the link in the description, or by going to keeps.com/wisecrack.
If you use our link, you can get 50% off your first order.
So stop stressing and keep your hair. And now back to the show advertising,
as we know,
it is somewhat of a newcomer in society's development prior to the invention of
the printing press. For instance, when most people were illiterate,
advertising mostly took the form of symbols,
like an Advil signifying that you were a blacksmith.
If you walk through a public square,
you would often be accosted by enterprising peddlers and public criers who
spread news about product shipments, theatrical performances,
and more as time went on as scholar Julian Silka explains in her book, soap,
sex and cigarettes advertising continued to reflect the cultural and
technological realities of the time.
Naturally when the printing press came around in the 15th century,
it led to an explosion in literacy and soon the emergence of printed ads,
newspapers became widespread in the 16 hundreds and by the 17 hundreds were all
aboard the ad train.
But the big campaigns you associate with Campbell soup or Coca-Cola were nowhere
to be seen. That is until a little thing called America happened.
And I don't mean America's endless thirst for cocaine, Jews,
English entrepreneurs in the 17th and 18th century tried luring people to the
new world,
but the promise of free land in exchange for labor in what was one of the first
concerted and sustained advertising campaigns,
condensed history of the modern world.
According to historian Richard Hofstadter, the ads are mostly lost to time,
but the sentiment can be seen in engravings of the time,
which typically and creepily embodied America as an Indian queen in a lush
landscape ads,
accordingly presented America as a garden of Eden full of gold and fountains of
youth and abundant land. But this successful plan had one minor hiccup.
America was a total sausage party with men outnumbering.
Women's six to one in Virginia and Maryland.
The Virginia company stepped in with of course,
an ad campaign addressing this lack.
They'd literally give you a wife in exchange for 120 pounds of decent tobacco
cause you know, romance,
but otherwise a world developing America didn't generally have much use for
advertising at the time most Americans lived in self-sustaining farms where they
produced everything they needed still,
there were some ads and it's very important and depressing to note that a large
percentage of them were advertising rewards for black people who had escaped
slavery. This was only the beginning of an extremely ugly history of racism and
advertising full of disturbing imagery.
We're not going to show you because woof,
but in the early 18 hundreds sweeping changes about to transform the country and
its advertising for good que the first industrial revolution,
suddenly manufacturers were able to make products so cheaply that it costs less
to buy lots of your household goodies than to make them as a new network of
railroads. And waterways began to snake around the country.
Shipping costs fell also growing urbanization meant fewer people growing food,
meaning they had to actually buy it around this time.
Crafting advertisements started to become a real profession though.
Not quite Don Draper, Swank defied, good Americans were consuming more,
but our country wasn't primarily driven by consumer spending. Not yet,
at least it would take the civil war to really turn American consumption into
the engine of our economy. So vocal sites to central reasons,
it changed the entire economy. First,
the war mainstream factory made food and clothing amongst hundreds of thousands
of soldiers, thus rendering them more willing to buy,
say mass produced suits or canned goods in the future. And second,
with all the men at war women now had to pick up the Slack in the fields and at
the factories, leaving them less time for their household tasks like cooking,
sewing, and soap, making advertisements at the time, weren't very sophisticated,
mostly relying on the hard sell style of advertising,
which is all about capturing the consumers attention in straightforward ways,
telling them why they need your product and why it's the best.
This can be particularly seen in patent medicine ads of the time,
which often hard sold solutions that just didn't work.
Hadn't medicine and medical quackery skyrocketed from the end of the civil war
until the end of the century becoming one-third of all American publishers
revenue by the turn of the century.
This was in part because so many wounded soldiers became addicted to wartime
drugs, which included cocaine and opiate also lousy diets,
lots of disease and increased settlement out West meant more.
People didn't have access to a trained doctor. So why not try caskets candy,
cathartic patent medicine salesmen also predicted another increasingly important
aspect of advertising packaging. You know,
the stuff surrounding your new purchase that you promptly discard cheap mass
production of packaging materials.
After the civil war doesn't sound like the most exciting thing in the world,
but trust us, it changed the game completely.
It allowed for brand differentiation and ushered in a host of new marketing
techniques, including trademarks. Instead of buying a plain barrel of oatmeal,
people were increasingly saving their money for brand named goods based solely
on packaging and branding exemplified by the Quaker oats guy who was born around
this time. But advertisers had a growing problem.
They'd have to face a lot of Americans, wary of tacky,
pet and medicine ads found mass consumption and the advertising that fueled it
dishonest and distasteful. So in the final decades of the 19th century,
advertisers tried to rebrand consumerism as a force of progress.
Ads began spotlighting the power of the consumer to contribute to American
progress specifically by choosing the right products,
a piano for your budding Bouswami daughter,
the right soap that would make you into a better mother or the stove Polish that
would get you into the Congress. No real,
this fit right in with the political values of his time,
which celebrated morality efficiency, many,
a successful advertising campaign piggybacked off of technological reforms of
the time,
which did everything from mainstream electricity to improve public transit.
This certainly wouldn't be the last time advertisers exploited political values
to overcome consumer skepticism, political values.
Aside the turn of the 20th century saw the rise of the mass produced luxury,
good product.
You probably can't afford that you hadn't heard of until you saw a compelling
ad. Consumers needed to be educated about these new products and why they needed
them. A prime example was the Kodak camera, a novelty,
which brought the art of photography to the home. In 1888,
you can see the advertiser trying to Sue the unfamiliar aspiring selfie taker
with the slogan. You press the button. We do the rest.
Another luxury product of the era was the bicycle,
which early ads educated consumers on how they even worked in the first place.
Once the product generated a craze, however,
advertisers switched to depicting fun countryside, sporty enjoyment,
and pretty women at the turn of the century.
Advertisers had solidified their strategy into two major schools of thought one,
the affirmation should hard sell,
or here's why you need this can opener then to the soft sell or
atmospheric ads,
which promised that buying a new piano would give you the luxurious lifestyle
you've been chasing as we'll see advertisers would often inhibit depending on
how healthy or absolutely screwed the economy was.
Start with the good times in the twenties production double as once thrifty
Americans started buying expensive products by installment.
All ad people had to do was come up with creative ways to separate folks from
their money. And boy did they succeed lifestyle and leisure ads,
reign Supreme portraying the message that consuming wasn't about buying what you
needed to survive. It was about buying what you wanted to enhance your status.
Ad makers stress this through their frequent portrayals of upper-class women who
indulged in the fashions of the time and not just fashionable clothes.
So notes that in this age,
manufacturers began using color and designed to sell everything from box to
silverware, to underway in the process.
She writes manufacturers transformed utilitarian staples into fashion goods.
You'll need a hat and handbag to match your new shoes. And so on.
Not only did advertisers invent reasons,
you needed different handbags to match your different shoes,
they invented all kinds of other weird reasons. You needed to buy their stuff.
Hilariously cool advertisements,
shamed women by inventing fake medical terms like halitosis I E bad
breath and warning them that they would be often a bridesmaid,
but never a bride unless they bought breath. Deodorant.
This is also around the time where razor manufacturers decided to double their
market by convincing women that they needed to shave their legs and pits.
But a problem comes with economic growth.
How do you get people to buy even more after your consumer buys one toaster,
they may not need another one for years or decades,
and that's not good for business.
So advertisers invent even more kinds of soft selling in the 1950s
manufacturers began employing dynamic obsolescence and nicer term for planned
obsolescence that focused on design and colors. Whereas in the past,
you might've kept your toaster for all 10 years of its functionality.
You would now to start it in favor of a cuter hipper toaster and do so with a
smile in the wake of America's new economic power.
This strategy helped foster the strongest consumer economy we'd ever seen.
This was a time when consumers bought things on credit and they were encouraged
to own two cars, several television sets,
and two shop excessively colored towels and handbags weren't enough anymore.
The central status symbol at the time was a modern kitchen with a new color.
The appliances doubling as fashion statements,
the rising prominence of psychology also gave advertisers some new tools to work
with people's subconscious cue motivation research, or Mr.
Which employed similar psychoanalytical tools used by father of public
relations. Edward Bernays,
as early as the 1920s motivation research had to figure out why people bought
things on both the subconscious and unconscious level,
suggesting that consumers don't actually know what they want and said,
seek out items for two main motivators sex and secure.
As a result of bra ads tried to tap into women's supposedly exhibitionist
tendencies, all camel cigarettes, route them with doctors,
assurances that smoking was good for you.
Skip ahead to the 1980s and you'll see a consumer market much like the 1950s,
but on lots of cocaine, people didn't just want to keep up with the Joneses.
They wanted to blow them out of the water.
Advertisers were all about reaching the ultra consumer who drank Perrier or
Ralph Lauren and drove a Mercedes ultra consumers also worked their butts off in
pursuit of nice things.
Leaving Alka seltzer to make a commercial promising relief for the stress of
success. Of course, prosperity can't last forever.
And advertisers have repeatedly over the 20th century,
had to relearn how to sell to thrifty folks.
This occurred most notably after the collapse of the stock market in 1929,
cue the hard, but make it neat. Many 1930s ads,
prey quite openly on existing emotions like guilt, fear, shame,
blame adds warned mothers of the perils of not buying their children milk and
urged men to buy Fleischmann's yeast cakes or risk being a failure.
Again in 1975,
advertisers would be faced with a quandary of selling to people who didn't have
much money after another recession.
Naturally they revive the great depression style, hard sell aggression,
especially through monotonous repetition.
Yeah.
Puts it. Creativity had turned into a rational quantifiable science with ads,
less interested in fashion or lifestyle than in convincing consumers that their
products would get the job done. Even when pocket books were light,
advertisers came in heavy. Of course,
there's one decade that doesn't quite fit the mold of human Buster advertising
the 1960s.
Similar to how in the 1890s advertisers had to appeal to progress to make up for
the bad rap marketing had gotten sixties.
Advertisers had to deal with open hostility to consumerism brought on by
counterculture and hippies.
So to not seem like some kind of lame stiff advertising, embraced creativity,
liberation, and sticking it to the man.
This is best exemplified by one of the decades.
Most famous campaigns that have the VW beetle,
these ads were creative self-deprecating and emphasize the unchanging nature of
the VW.
Soon advertisers started targeting the youth with psychedelic imagery and
younger models. They also convinced the generation of people.
I eat boomers who allegedly care about planet earth to embrace disposable,
everything from blow-up furniture to pop art ceramics advertisers also
piggybacked off the burgeoning movement for civil rights and women's rights
incorporating, or if you're cynical like us,
arguably co-opted their messaging into advertising,
but we haven't talked about the two gigantic leaps in advertising technology,
television, and the internet commercial broadcasting began in the 1940s.
And by 1960 advertisers could reach nearly every American home via the boob
tube. But at first TV advertising looked a lot different than it does today.
Early television programming was largely controlled entirely by their sponsors.
For example, I love Lucy was owned by Philip Morris.
One of the first TV hits was the Texaco star theater,
which both opened and closed on a shot of four Texaco gas station worker
singing.
This was all fine and good until the trademark fifties network quiz shows were
revealed to be rigged by advertisers who kept popular contestants on the show
longer in order to earn more money networks and advertisers alike soon renounced
entirely sponsored content. And instead adopted commercial breaks.
We have come to know and hate relaxed regulation on advertisers in the 1980s
also meant the introduction of infomercials,
which allow your advertisement to go on and on and on.
Also increasingly ads became embedded in movies and TV shows by an increasing
use of product placement.
Thus further blurring the line between entertainment and advertising,
which brings us to the internet a whole new way,
advertisers to capture people's attention if they can only get them to click.
And as we'll see that weird lack of distinction between advertisement and
content seen in the Texaco star theater will really, and truly haunt us.
We have to start with the beginning, the banner ad and the pop-up ad,
which redirected you to the typically very janky homepage of a mega corporation,
early internet advertising work hard to differentiate the ad from the regular
website content highly effective. At first,
the first banner ad for at T and T in 1994,
got 44% of viewers to click on it.
But we're soon dismissed as boring and ineffective today,
fewer than 0.1% of users click on a given banner ad. Unlike TV,
the internet has always been a tricky place to advertise because consumers are
in control over what they interact with or are willing to sit through.
But in the new millennium,
advertisers would go from wanting to get your attention to wanting to get
something more your heart.
And the two thousands advertising got really personal with brands wanting to
form relationships with their consumers.
The product itself becomes increasingly irrelevant and sometimes even invisible.
Like this is an advertisement for Cadbury. What's more,
the rise of social media created new ways for consumers to interact with brands,
which has been exploited to varying usually humorous and troubling degrees
brands will now just straight up, try to act like people.
The goal is if you feel fondly about the olive gardens, social media presence,
it's a lot more likely that you're not just going to buy a basket of
breadsticks.
You're going to be the envy of your friends and buy a freaking pasta pass.
It. Wasn't.
Just brands trying to connect with you on a personal level.
Advertisements themselves became personalized. We saw the rise of targeted ads,
which required consumer surveillance often on the part of online mega giants
like Google and Facebook who have increasingly intricate profiles of each user
based on search history, demographics and interests.
Probably the biggest development of the time though,
is the way advertising has become increasingly stealthy on the internet.
Banner ads and popups were largely replaced with search advertising in big part,
thanks to Google's invention of ad sense in 2003,
which allows any web publisher to host cost per click contextual ads based on
Google search history.
This can obviously make it more difficult to distinguish between real search
results and promoted sites. Another growing phenomenon,
native advertising allows for everything from sponsored editorial content that
seamlessly incorporates a brand into a news article to Instagram influencers,
invisibly, integrating ads for vitamin gummies,
ultimately making the line between ad and information slash entertainment,
all but invisible way more subtle version of the Texaco show.
Content marketing too has exploded with corporations producing their own
magazines games. And of course,
viral videos often focused on addressing consumer needs as seen in the lows
fixed in six home improvement ads,
increasingly we're consuming advertising without realizing or in spite of it
being advertising possibly the best example of a 21st century corporation
pursuing all the possibilities of the new age of advertising can be seen with
red bull,
which has over the past two decades checked all the modern marketing boxes with
its own media company that produces TV, magazines, music games, and more.
They employed everything from celebrity slash influencer endorsements to
sponsoring music festivals, to acquiring thousands of brand ambassadors,
to hand out their product for free.
They also host events like break dancing competitions and organized social media
stunts like this guy jumping from space.
Of course the result is a weird advertiser mediated reality.
When our news can be sponsored by jet blue,
a sporting event can be planned and executed by red bull and even dollar shave
club has its own media arm, which to be honest is weirdly good.
How much of our culture is just some weird way to sell you something?
Will there be some backlash like there was against sponsored game shows or are
we stuck in this nightmare forever, but what do you guys think?
Let us know in the comments, big, big,
thanks to our patrons and advertisers for supporting our channel and podcast hit
that subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching guys.
Peace
[inaudible].